Now we know what is the information in one random
variable. Now assume that I told you to predict if you're
going to hear thunder or not. Well, that's very difficult. But
what if I tell you if it is raining or not.
Your guess regarding the thunder is going to be significantly better.
So there is some information in this variable that tells you
something about this variable. We can measure that in two different
ways. The first one is called as joint entropy. Joint entropy
is the randomness contained in two variables together as given
by H of X comma Y. And, as you can
predict, it is given by this particular formula, which is
the joint probability distribution between X and Y. And, as you
predicted, it is given by this particular formula where P
of X comma Y is the joint probability of X and
Y. The other measure is called as conditional entropy. Conditional
entropy is a measure of the randomness of one variable given
the other variable. And it is generated by H
of Y given X. Now, to understand these two concepts,
you have to imagine what happens when X and Y
are independent. If X and Y are independent, then the
conditional probability of Y given X is just the
conditional probability of Y. It's quite obvious, right. If two
variables are independent of each other, Y variable doesn't get
any information from X at all. The joint entropy between
X and Y, if X and Y are independent, is the sum of information
of both X and Y. That is why the entropies have been added here.